I know you're a good dude because
whenever I say some that on
women you're like yo I feel that no but
not in like I'm a bad husband way and
like yeah no I'm kind of miserable too
that's the mark of a good man I can see
this guy right now looks tired as
Saturday at 8 30 p.m and look at this
he's exhausted we're trying
to make you happy I know I've been there
hey bro I got you bro I got you see they
don't want us to be happy I don't even
know each other she's slapping your hand
it's unbelievable he's got no soul left
to laugh because he's too tired gives me
a letter grade on each one of my jokes I
also be plus anytime I say something
conservative he's like that's a
plus right there you're a good dude it's
just you vote red and blue lives matter
that's it these are your colors
uh you say that because you probably own
a lot of guns I bet you know what an
easy target is I've already said when I
got on stage you're like I shot this
cardboard version of him
many times you're gonna take it out on
me tomorrow the gun range I bet you're
gonna print out a picture of me and just
put that up on the face of a black
silhouette and be like well it's better
when I'm shooting the black guy but I'm
gonna take it out on this one this time